الى بريطانيا حيث توقعوا لندن وطوكيو
اليوم اتفاقيه دفاع المشترك بتزامني مع
زياره رئيس الوزراء الياباني فورميو
وكاشيدال العاصمه البريطانيا
القانونيه اللازمه فضلا عن تحديد اولويات
التعاون العسكري وتسهيل التدريبات
المشتركه
وهي تاتي اليوم بعد شهر من تعاون البلدين
مع ايطاليا في برنامج جديد لتطوير طائرات
المقاتله من الجيل الثاني
في بيان ان بريطانيا ستكون اول دوله
اوروبيه لديها مثل هذه الاتفاقيه مع
اليابان واعتبر انها اهم
اتفاقياتهم مشترك بين البلدين منذ 120
عاما
تنضم الينا من طوكيو مراسله الجزيره مع
سموره مها بريطانيا ترى ان هذه الاهميه
الاتفاقيه هي الاهم بين البلدين منذ 100
عام ما الذي تقوله اليابان بخصوص هذه
الاتفاقيه وما اهميتها بالنسبه لها
وصلت اليابان والمملكه المتحده الى
المرحله النهائيه من ابرام اتفاق امنيا
عسكريا تاريخي بسبب المخاوف المشتركه من
غزوي روسيا لاوكرانيا وانشطه الهيمنه
الصينيه هذا وسيوقعوا رئيس الوزراء
الياباني
سنه في برج لندن اتفاقيه الدفاع من شانها
ان تضع اثاره قانونيه لانشطه قوات الدفاع
الذاتيه في بريطانيا والافراد العسكريين
البريطانيين في اليابان استراليا هي حتى
الان الدوله الوحيده التي قامت اليابان
مثل هذا في اتفاقي معها حتى مع قيام
دولتين الرامي هذا الاتفاق وحتى بعد
التوقيع من يكون خارج المفعول الى بعد ان
يتم عرض على البرلمان والقيام باجراء
ترتيبات المحليه القانونيه حيث من المفترض
ان تقوم اليابان بعرض هذه البنود في جلسه
البرلمانيه
خلال الاسبوع المقبل بالنسبه لاهم هذه
البنود هي ستتناول التنازل عن همم شروط
التحقق من الاقامه والهجره للافراد
عسكريين الوافدين او المقيمين في البلدان
المغيره وتسهيل اجراءات جلد الاسلحه
والذخيره واا القيام بالقيام باجراءات او
تدريبات العسكريه المشتركه
وعلى عكس همم
اتفاقيه الولايات المتحده واليابان وفي من
شانها ان تكون تتمركز او همم تكون همم
يكون وضع القوات الامريكيه في اليابان
لمده طويله من الزمن سيكون هناك تحديد
سياسه لتحديد المواقع لكل البلدين بشكل
متبادل ان هو متساوي بالنسبه للتعاون
المشترك بين الولايات المتحده واليابان قد
تم حتى الان العديد من المناورات العسكريه
المشتركه بين القوات الدفاع الذاتيه
الياباني والجيش البريطاني حيث ان همم
امن اوروبا
المحيطين الهندي لا ينفصلان شكرا جزيلا لك
ما همم سموره